vamos a tratar de darle el nombre a esta
molécula muy enmarañada que tenemos aquí
como siempre hemos iniciado primero
tenemos que encontrar la cadena de
carbono es más larga verdad entonces por
ejemplo si empezamos por aquí podríamos
contar 1 2 3 4 5 si si subimos serían 6
y 7 o bien si seguimos por acá sería 6 7
8 9 10
si fuéramos por acá abajo serían 7 8
verdad entonces la cadena más larga en
efecto es esta de acá si por ejemplo nos
fuéramos para acá abajo pues no sería
tan larga como esta de acá arriba verdad
entonces nuestra cadena más larga es
justamente esta de aquí
esta de aquí que tiene además 10
carbonos verdad eso fue lo que contamos
tiene 10 carbonos y en ese caso esta
molécula sería decano verdad sería
decano déjeme ponerlo más arriba sería
un decano ahora bien ya que tenemos la
molécula más larga además es un arcano
verdad porque tenemos puros enlaces
simples y por eso es que tiene
terminación a no tiene prefijo deck
porque son 10 ahora vamos a tratar de
ubicar cuáles son los grupos al kilo que
tenemos en esta molécula y por ejemplo
tenemos esta de esta de aquí este es un
grupo al kilo que tiene dos carbonos
quiere decir que este es un grupo de
tilos verdad
el grupo de tilos este también es un
grupo de tilos verdad tiene dos carbonos
y está unido a nuestra cadena principal
ahora cuál sería el nombre de esta de
este grupo que tenemos acá arriba
entonces tenemos este grupo de aquí
este grupo de aquí que consta de tres
carbonos verdad tiene tres carbonos
entonces este es un grupo pro pilot este
es un grupo pro pilot y por supuesto no
no estás mal si por ejemplo de entrada
tú dijiste que sólo era un grupo propio
y la verdad es es parte de sus
características sin embargo no es un
propio cualquiera este es un el carbono
al que está unido la cadena es un
carbono secundario y es secundario
porque a su vez en el grupo se encuentra
unido a otros dos entonces como está
unido a otros dos carbonos es un es un
carbono secundario si estuviera unido a
otros tres sería un carbono terciario si
estuviera unido a un solo carbono sería
un grupo algún carbono primario verdad
entonces tenemos un por un grupo propio
pero que además está unido en el carbón
en un carbono secundario entonces este
es un
propio verdad y vimos que puede
escribirse solo como ese propio o bien
éste también tiene el nombre de
isopropílico
y su propia verdad ahora bien esto es si
le asignamos su nomenclatura como en
verdad cuál sería cuál sería la
nomenclatura sistemática bueno pues para
la nomenclatura sistemática nosotros
necesitamos tratar este grupo como si
fuera una cadena digamos de alcano es
verdad entonces empezamos de nuestro
punto en donde se une a la cadena
principal y encontramos la cadena más
larga aquí en este grupo que en este
caso corresponde a este verdad entonces
en este caso nuestra digamos sub cadena
más importante es como si fuera un grupo
de tilos verdad esto es un estilo vamos
a dejarlo como útil ok y ahora bien
tenemos un único carbono uno solo unido
a nuestra sub cadena verdad entonces
este es un grupo metilo unido a este
otro grupo entonces además no está unido
en cualquier carbono si no está unido en
el primer carbono de estos dos entonces
esto lo podemos escribir como 1
metil etil verdad entonces todo esto
representa a está digamos sub cadena oa
esta subestructura muy bien ya que
tenemos todos los grupos identificados
ya tenemos qué tipo de alcano es cuántos
carbonos tiene ahora nos corresponde
enumerar los carbonos de la cadena
principal para que podamos encontrar más
grupos de forma más rápida que quiero ir
con esto por ejemplo si si enumeramos de
este extremo a este otro sería 1 2 3 4 5
en el en el quinto carbono encontramos
dos grupos verdad mientras que si
enumeramos al revés tendremos 1 2 3 4 5
también está en el quinto carbono pero
tenemos menos sólo tenemos un grupo
entonces la forma en la que hay que
enumerar es de esta forma verdad porque
de así encontramos más grupos de forma
más rápida
ok entonces ya que están enumerados
ahora si podemos darle nombre a esto
verdad le podemos dar nombre primero
seguramente te estarás preguntando cómo
podríamos asignar los nombres en qué
orden y el orden en el que vamos a
hacerlo es es muy sencillo nos vamos a
fijar en la primera letra de estos
grupos y nos fijamos que bueno tenemos
que asignar los por orden alfabético y
en el caso del sectro pilo generalmente
cuando tiene prefijos potter se eliminan
y nos consideramos simplemente esto es
verdad en este caso sería metil pero
bueno en el caso en el caso digamos que
estemos trabajando con el nombre común
con el nombre común sería el siguiente
verdad vamos a fijarnos ahorita en el id
vamos a ponerle de nombre hizo propio
muy bien para no hacer dos ejemplos
entonces nos fijamos que la e va antes
que la y verdad de hecho también va
antes que la p
pero bueno entonces el nombre digamos el
nombre común de esta molécula sería dos
veces estilo nes
damos un dietil verdad tenemos un día
útil ahora bien no basta con eso hay que
decir en qué carbonos están entonces
está en el 5 y en el 6
dietil y tenemos un piso propio tenemos
un piso propio en el quinto carbono
entonces tenemos un 5 hizo propi lo hizo
propio el perdón de khan muy bien
entonces este sería el nombre o más bien
que le asignamos con la nomenclatura
común si consideramos este nombre
entonces que lo que tendríamos
tendríamos nuevamente 56 dietil verdad y
tenemos esta estructura que es en el en
el 5º carbono tenemos esta estructura en
el quinto carbono sería el uno metil
etil
1 metil etil bueno déjame ponerlo con el
mismo color
es el metil etil cerramos y simplemente
nos resulta de kano verdad que ponemos
decano entonces ahí tienen dos formas
válidas para nombrar a esta molécula la
primera es simplemente utilizando la
nomenclatura común y la segunda es
utilizando la nomenclatura sistemática